among us right now and it's uh
it's it's a great score two games out of
two
yeah um i think uh in the second game uh
he uh
had a very good position from uh from
the opening uh was clearly uh
clearly uh quite a bit worse um
i think uh the key turning point of the
game was when he allowed me to to play
a5 and uh
thus gaining some counter play i think
he still had a good position but
after that um
the fact that i had something to to play
for that he had some weaknesses as well
instead of the game being completely
one-sided uh combined with
his
uh lack of time which uh
which to be fair he's very used to but
still not an advantage
um
so that was uh
um
yeah that was that was a key turning
point after that i
didn't feel so pessimistic
and obviously he might uh
he made a tactical blunder there missing
uh missing a queen sack
followed by
by by a fork but these blenders don't
usually come out of of nothing i think
the trend for me was already very
good i don't know if i was
anyway considerably better yet but
i don't think i was worse anymore do you
think you'll be able to show us an
extremely boring drawish white game now
we'll see good luck thank you